سمح المدعون البريطانيون
بتهم جنائية ضد الممثل كيفن
سبيسي ، حيث تضمنت أربع تهم
بالاعتداء الجنسي ضد ثلاثة رجال في
تهمة خامسة خطيرة للغاية هنا تتمثل في التسبب
في انخراط شخص في نشاط جنسي مخترق
دون موافقة الرجال أه
الضحايا الآن في الثلاثينيات من العمر و
وقعت هذه الحوادث المزعومة في الأربعينيات
بين عامي 2005 و 2013 ، لكن المفتاح الذي يجب
ملاحظته هنا هو أن النيابة العامة البريطانية
قد أذنت بهذه
التهم الجنائية لكن الممثل لم
يستلمها رسميًا بعد لأنه ليس
هنا في إنجلترا ، فهو ليس هنا في لندن.
بشكل عام في هذه الحالات ، ما يمكن أن
يحدث هو أن الشخص المعني
يمكن للمتهم العودة إلى إنجلترا يمكنه
العودة إلى لندن ومواجهة هذه
التهم إذا لم يفعل كيفن سبيسي أن
النيابة العامة
البريطانية لها
الحق في متابعة إجراءات التسليم
مع  الولايات المتحدة الآن
السلطات هنا حتى الآن رفضت
التعليق ورفض أه القول إن كان أم
لن يتابعوا إجراءات التسليم هذه ،
لكن هذا جزء من
عملية جنائية طويلة ومعقدة للغاية ، حيث
قالت أجهزة النيابة العامة الملكية
إن هذا إجراء جنائي مستمر ، ومن
حق كيفن سبيسي
بالطبع الحصول على محاكمة عادلة في
شرطة لندن قائلاً إنهم سيفعلون ذلك لاحقًا.
قم بتحديث الجمهور بتاريخ محدد عندما
يتلقى أه كيفن سبيسي هذه
التهم رسميًا ،
هذه الادعاءات ضد كيفن
سبيسي مستمرة الآن منذ سنوات منذ
حركة أنا أيضًا في عام 2017 عندما تم
اتهامه لأول مرة في الولايات المتحدة ،
ثم اتهم لاحقًا بممارسة الجنس
سوء السلوك هنا في لندن في مسرح Vic القديم
ورائي هنا حيث كان
المدير الإبداعي والمدير الفني
بدلاً من ذلك
بين عامي 2004 و 2015 ، لذا فإن النافذة عندما
تحدث هذه الحوادث المزعومة ،
فهذا تحديث إضافي آخر
في هذه العملية الطويلة جدًا الآن فصاعدًا  وصل
جزء من kevin spacey cnn
إلى ممثليه للتعليق ولكن
لم يوص بعد  أي رد فعل بعض
هؤلاء سي إن إن لندن